we're just going to take you straight to
Munich security conference and the Prime
Minister wish you soon act let's listen
just this year we became the first
country in the world to provide tanks to
Ukraine and the first to train pilots
and Marines
we gave 2.3 billion pounds last year and
we will match or exceed that in 2023 now
other allies can tell a similar story
and our Collective efforts are making a
difference
but with every day that passes
Russian forces inflict yet more pain and
suffering
now the only way to change that
is for Ukraine to win
[Applause]
so we need a military strategy for
Ukraine to gain a decisive advantage on
the battlefield to win the war
and a political strategy to win the
peace
to win the war Ukraine needs more
artillery armored vehicles and air
defense so now is the moment to double
down on our military support
when Putin started this war he gambled
that our resolve would falter
even now he is betting that we will lose
our nerve
but we proved him wrong then and we will
prove him wrong now
together we're delivering as much
equipment in the next few months as in
the whole of 2022.
and together we must help Ukraine to
Shield its cities from Russian bombs and
Iranian drones
and that's why the United Kingdom will
be the first country to provide Ukraine
with longer range weapons and it's why
we're working with our allies to give
Ukraine the most advanced air defense
systems and build the Air Force they
need to defend their Nation now of
course the United Kingdom stands ready
to help any country provide planes that
Ukraine can use today
but we must also train Ukrainian Pilots
to use the most advanced Jets and that's
exactly what Britain is doing so that
Ukraine has the capability to defend its
security for the long term
but to win the peace we also need to
rebuild the international order on which
our collective security depends
first that means upholding international
law
the whole world must hold Russia to
account
we must see Justice
through the ICC for their sickening war
crimes committed
whether in butcher Urban Mario Pole or
Beyond
and Russia must also be held to account
for the terrible destruction it has
inflicted
we are hosting the Ukraine recovery
conference in London this June and we
should consider together how to ensure
that Russia pays towards that
reconstruction
[Applause]
now second the treaties and agreements
of the post-cold War era have failed
Ukraine
so we need a new framework for its
long-term security
from human rights to Reckless nuclear
threats from Georgia to Moldova Russia
has committed violation after violation
against countries outside the collective
security of NATO
and the international community's
response has not been strong enough
as Jen stoltenberg has said Ukraine will
become a member of NATO
but until that happens we need to do
more to bolster Ukraine's long-term
security
we must give them the Advanced NATO
standard capabilities that they need for
the future
astray that will remain by their side
willing and able to help them defend
their country again and again
Ukraine needs and deserves assurances of
that support So ahead of the NATO Summit
in Vilnius we will bring together our
friends and allies to begin building
those long-term assurances
and our aim should
Forge a new Charter in Vilnius to help
protect Ukraine from future Russian
aggression
now let me conclude with one final
thought
what's at stake in this war
is even greater than the security and
sovereignty of one nation
it's about the security and sovereignty
of every nation
because Russia's Invasion it's abhorrent
war crimes and irresponsible nuclear
rhetoric are symptomatic of a broader
threat to everything we believe in
from the Skies over North America
to the suffering on the streets of
Tehran
some would destabilize the order that
has preserved peace and stability for 80
years
they must not Prevail and we need not be
daunted
as president zielinski said when he
addressed the UK Parliament last week
we are Marching towards the most
important victory of our lifetime
it will be a victory over the very idea
of War
and we could have no greater purpose
than to prove him right thank you
Department